White House chief of staff General John
Kelly retired Marine general whose own
son was killed defending this country in
Afghanistan in 2010 absolutely unloaded
on congresswoman Frederica Wilson the
Democrats and the media earlier today it
was so emotional so movie and the best
takedown of the press I have ever seen
we're going to show you all of general
Kelly's comments must-see comments in
just a second but first let me explain
how the liberal media the Trump hating
congresswoman Frederica Wilson are
exploiting the death of an American hero
in one of these most disgusting displays
in American history I'm gonna take this
is sick this is repulsive it proves what
we've been telling you the left in this
country has zero moral compass and they
will use anyone and anything to bludgeon
President Trump now Sargent law David
Johnson he's an American Hero
he laid down his life defending this
country but instead of honoring his
sacrifice and his family and trying to
comfort his heartbroken and grieving
family what do we have the liberal
ideological mainstream media we have a
congresswoman who hates president Trump
Frederica Wilson using the dead body of
an American soldier as a pawn in their
sick and twisted political game to take
down the president now just look at some
this is a tiny sampling of the many
shameful ways the liberal mainstream
media is exploiting sergeant Johnson's
death all to attack the president watch
this it's nauseating he's so quick with
a tweet with a tweet why didn't we hear
just basic condolences to the four men
who fell in Neesha are the four
Americans who gave their lives for the
country in these years because he tweets
about things he cares about Willie but
no one can point to what no supporter of
Donald Trump can point to is a shred of
public evidence that Donald Trump cares
about any pain that is not his own
there is simply no evidence that
anyone's description of their pain can
reach
Donald Trump the problem that President
Trump might have here however is that
when it comes to sensitivity when it
comes to sensitivity about service and
sacrifice specifically he's already made
what critics have assessed to be some
grievously bad decisions it is another
example of president Trump's willingness
to go lower than anyone else in American
politics to try to build himself up and
it is disgraceful this just shows you
how morally bankrupt the media in this
country is to them nothing including the
death of an American soldier is
off-limits
when it comes to bashing President Trump
what they are doing is beyond
disrespectful beyond the pale the media
is literally spitting on the graves of
every single American who has died
defending this country and their rights
to be stupid like they are every day
then there's democratic congresswoman
Frederica Wilson oh she's the number one
Trump hater in the country what she's
engaging in in orchestrating here is the
epitome of gutter bottom-of-the-barrel
politics this woman is a disgrace to the
US Congress and doesn't have an ounce of
shame in her body
Frederica Wilson saw the death of
sergeant Johnson oh just as a way to
manufacture a controversy and try and
hurt the president and that's exactly
what she's doing
watch this there's no reason for the
president to be so insensitive
not only to the family of this soldier
but then pervious rhetoric is you know
it's disrespectful to the family of
every soldier this man is a sick man
he's cold-hearted and he feels no pity
or sympathy for anyone this might wind
up to be mr. Trump's Benghazi so the
president evidently is lying because
what I said it's trying a reason to lie
on the President of the United States he
needs to learn from past presidents like
President Obama and be presidential
during times like this this gentleman
has a brain disorder and he needs to be
checked out really congresswoman your
deep hatred of this part
shows no bounds no limits what kind of
person is doing what congressman Wilson
is doing here think about this for a
second how low how pathetic do you have
to be to try and manipulate the tragic
death of an American Hero for bitter
partisan political gain make no mistake
this shouldn't be a surprise coming from
congresswoman Frederica Wilson she has a
very long history of doing nothing else
but trashing president Trump the media
hasn't told you about this part
Wilson has called for the president's
impeachment she's labeled him a racist
she said he was crazy and the list of
insults I can go on and on and on but
here's the bottom line
congresswoman Wilson is a national
disgrace
her conduct is beneath the position that
she has in the US Congress Congress and
while all of this is going on the White
House chief of staff general Kelley
retired general now cold star parent has
been sitting back watching what the
media and the Democrats are doing and
keep in mind unlike most of the
president's critics general Kelley
actually knows what it means to serve
the country and more importantly general
Kelley actually knows the unimaginable
pain of losing a family member in combat
by the way he never got a call from
President Obama but earlier today John
Kelly general Kelly stepped into the
White House briefing room and unloaded
rightly so on congresswoman Wilson and
the media for their disgusting shameless
political tactics and Kelly's emotional
and powerful response is the single best
takedown of the media I've ever seen
we're gonna show you all of it watch
this
most Americans don't know what happens
when we lose one of our soldiers sailors
airmen Marines or Coast Guardsmen in
combat so let me tell you what happens
they're buddies wrap them up in whatever
passes there's a shroud puts them on a
helicopter as a routine and sends them
home their first stop along the way is
when they're packed and ice
typically at the at the airhead and then
they're flown to use a Europe where
they're then packed on ice again in
flown to Dover Air Force Base where
Dover takes care of the remains and
bombs them meticulously dresses them in
their uniform with the rebel with the
medals that they've earned the emblems
of their service and then puts them on
another airplane linked up with a
casualty officer escort that takes them
home a very very good movie to watch if
you haven't ever seen it just taking
chance where this is done in a movie HBO
setting chance Phelps was killed under
my command right next to me and it's
worth seeing that if you've never seen
it so that's the process
well that's happening a casualty officer
typically goes to the home very early in
the morning and waits for the first
lights to come on and then he knocks on
the door
typically the mom and dad will answer
wife and if there is a wife this is
happening in two different places if the
parents are divorced three different
places and the casualty casualty officer
proceeds to break the heart of a family
member and stays with that family until
well for a long long time even after the
internment so that's what happens who
are these young men and women they are
the best 1% this country produces most
of you as Americans don't know them many
of you don't know anyone who knows any
of one of them but they are the very
best this country produces and they
volunteer to protect our country when
there's nothing in our country anymore
that seems to suggest that self service
to the nation is not only appropriate
but required but that's alright who
writes letters to the families typically
the company commander in my case is a
marine the company commander battalion
commander regimental commander division
commander secretary defense typically
the service chief com
the Marine Corps and the president
typically writes a letter typically the
only phone calls the family receives are
the most important phone calls they
could imagine and that is from their
buddies in my case hours after my son
was killed his friends were calling us
from Afghanistan telling us what a great
guy was I was it the only phone calls
that really matter and you know the the
letters count to a degree but there's
not much that really could take the edge
off what the family members going
through so some presidents have elected
to call all presidents I believe have
elected to send letters if you elect to
call a family like this it is about the
most difficult thing you could imagine
there's no perfect way to make that
phone call when I took this job and
talked to the President Trump about how
to do it my first recommendation was he
not do it because it's not the phone
call that parents family members are
looking forward to it's a nice to do in
my opinion in any event he asked me
about previous presidents and I said I
can tell you that President Obama who
was my trainer chief when I was on
active duty did not call my family that
was not a criticism that was just to
simply say I don't believe President
Obama called that's not a negative thing
I don't believe President Bush called in
all cases I don't believe any president
particularly when the casualty rates are
very very high that president's call but
I believe they all right so when I gave
that explanation to our president three
days ago he elected to make phone calls
in the case of the four young men who he
lost in niger at the earlier part of
this month but then he said you know
what how do you make these calls
if you're not in the family if you've
never worn the uniform if you've never
been in combat you can't even imagine
how to make that call
I think you very bravely does make those
calls the call in question that he made
yesterday day before yesterday now we're
to four family members the four fallen
and remember there's a next akin
designated by the individual if he's
married that's typically for what the
spouse if he's not married that's
typically the parents unless the parents
are divorced and then selects one of
them if you didn't get along with his
parents he'll sit you'll select a
sibling but the point is the phone call
is made to the next akin only if the
next two can agrees to take the phone
calls sometimes they don't so a pre call
was made president United States are the
carbonado Marine Corps
if someone would like to call will you
accept a call and typically they all
accept the call so he called four people
the other day and expressed his
condolences in the best way that he
could and he said to me what do I say I
said to him sir there's nothing you can
do to lighten the burden on these
families let me tell you what I tell him
let me tell you what my best friend Joe
Dunford told me because he was my
casualty officer he said Kel
he was doing exactly what he wanted to
do when he was killed he knew what he
was getting into by joining the more
that 1% he know what the possibilities
were because we're at war and when he
died in the four cases were talking
about and I assure my son's case in
Afghanistan when he died he was
surrounded about the best men on this
earth his friends that's what the
president tried to say to a fact of four
families the other day I was stunned
when I came to work yesterday morning
and brokenhearted at what I saw remember
Congress doing member Congress who
listened in on a phone call from the
president of States to a young wife and
in his way tried to express that opinion
there's a brave man fallen hero he knew
he was getting himself into because he
enlisted there's no reason to enlist he
enlisted and he was where he wanted to
be exactly where he wanted to be with
exactly the people he wanted to be with
when his life was taken that was the
message that was the message that was
transmitted it stuns me that a member of
Congress would have listened in on that
conversation absolutely stuns me and I
thought at least that was sacred you
know when I was a kid growing up a lot
of things were sacred in our country
women were sacred and looked upon with
great honor that's obviously not the
case anymore as received from recent
cases life that dignity of life was
sacred that's gone religion that seems
to be have gone as well gold star
families I think that left and the
convention over the summer I just
thought the selfless devotion that
brings a man or woman to die in the
battlefield I just thought that that
might be sacred when I listened to this
woman and what she was saying and what
she was doing on TV the only thing I
could do to collect my thoughts was to
go and walk among the finest men and
women on this earth and you can always
find them because they're in Arlington
National Cemetery when over there for an
hour and a half
walked among the stones some of whom I
put there because they were doing what I
told them to do when they were killed
I'll end with this in in in October
April's rather of 2015 are still on
active duty and I went to the dedication
of the new FBI field office in Miami and
it was dedicated to two men who were
killed in a firefight in Miami with
against drug traffickers in 1986 got
manemma Grogan and Duke Grogan almost
retired 53 years old Duke I think less
than a year on the job anyways I got in
a gun fight and they were killed three
others FBI agents were there were
wounded now retired so we go down Jim
Comey get an absolutely brilliant
memorial speech to those fallen men in
the in the to all of the men and women
of the FBI who serve our country so well
in law enforcement so well there were
family members there some of the
children that were there were only three
or four years old when their dads were
killed on that street in miami-dade
three of the men that survived the fight
were there and gave rendition of how
brave those men work and how they gave
their lives an a congresswoman stood up
and in the long tradition of empty
barrels making the most noise stood up
there and all of that and talked about
how she was instrumental in getting the
funding for that building now she took
care of her constituents because she got
the money and she just called up
President Obama and on that phone call
he gave the money the twenty million
dollars to build a building she sat down
and we were stunned stunned that she
done it even for someone that is that
empty of barrel
we was stunned but you know none of us
went to the press and criticized none of
us stood up and were appalled we just
said okay fine so I still hope as you
write your stories and I appeal to
America that let's not let this maybe
last thing that sells sacred in our in
our society a young man young woman
going out and giving his or her life for
our country let's let's try to somehow
keep that keep that sacred but it eroded
a great deal yesterday by the selfish
behavior of a member of Congress so I'm
willing to take a question or two on
this - on this topic but let me ask you
this let me ask you this does anyone
hear a gold star parent or sibling does
anyone here know a gold star parent or
sibling okay you get the question Thank
You general Kelly first of all you free
till respect simplify for everything
we're done but if we could take this a
bit further why were they in Niger what
was we were told they weren't in armored
vehicles and there was no air cover so
what are the specifics about this
particular incident and why were we
there then why are we there
well I would I would start by saying
there is an investigation there they're
working with partners local Africa all
across Africa in this case Niger working
with partners teaching them how to be
better soldiers teaching them how to
respect human rights teaching them how
to fight Isis so that we don't have to
send our soldiers and Marines there in
their thousands I mean what you know
what the hell is my son doing back in
the fight he's back in the fight because
working with Iraqi soldiers who are
infinitely better than they were a few
years ago to take Isis on directly so
that we don't have to do it small
numbers of Marines where he is working
alongside those guys that's why they're
out there whether it's Niger Iraq or
whatever we don't want to send tens of
thousands of American soldiers and
Marines in particular to go fight as I
walk off the stage understand these tens
of thousands of American kids mostly
doing the nations bidding all around the
world they don't have to be in the
inside you know when I was a kid every
man in my life for the veteran world
walk to Korea and there was a drug these
young people today they don't do it for
any other reason than their selfless
sense of selfless devotion to this great
nation we don't look down upon those of
you that haven't service in fact in a
way a little bit sorry because you'll
never experience the wonderful joy you
get in your heart when you do the kind
of things our servicemen and women
not for any other reason than they love
this country you just think of that I do
appreciate your time